this woman is a brilliant brilliant
artist in Rosanna de Soto does one of
the most extraordinary journey pieces of
work in this film Rosanna de Soto let's
go
thank you ready it was really truly a
pleasure to work in this project um the
role I played was that of the
interpreter somebody who tells this
person what that person is saying and
that position was really an interesting
challenge for me
I played cattle at dominoes and it's
probably the favorite role I've ever
done and I've done a few things and but
that's that's one of my favorite roles
what was the most challenging thing
about your role
Dolson well you know that's why it's
this film is so timely today because one
of the main challenges that we have as
human beings on this planet is being
understood by one another or
understanding one another and semantics
can play a huge role in in that when we
don't understand the other person
horrible things can happen there's a
lack of peace there's a war and so that
that's why I say it's a challenge
because that's the thing that we strive
for
that's what films music writers who do
plays and people who write novels and
educators and schools do the art the
true art is to be able to get people to
articulate clearly their feelings and
then to understand the feelings of
others wonderful thank you